the celebration on the las vegas strip
for the first time in more than a decade
a new hotel casino is opening up on las
vegas boulevard
we do thank you for joining us on what
is a big night in las vegas at 11 here
on 8 news now i'm brian loftis
resorts world now open on the north
strip been a long time coming the
project first broke ground back
in 2015. now we have team coverage
tonight sasha loftus
outside the property with reaction from
guests but first
orco mana inside resorts world tonight
and orco
it is quite a party in there you look
very dapper sir
[Applause]
well brian that's the perfect way to
describe the atmosphere here you can
hear
the cheering behind me the doors to
resorts world
just opened moments ago to the public
again just moments ago
here the public here in las vegas
entering as you mentioned grind
the newest resort here on the las vegas
trip as we said crowds of people have
been flocking here to check it out
and we want you to take a look here
here's a closer look at the property as
people
are entering you can see we've got a
really fancy
and really luxurious property and that's
exactly what
the resource world staff have been
telling us it's mixing luxury
with accommodations and comfortability
and this is what we're seeing here it's
a beautiful new property here on the
strip
and all the fun kicked off earlier
tonight with the ribbon cutting ceremony
three two one
and i mean what a way to celebrate a
grand opening
in las vegas there was also a ceremonial
dragon dance
and lion blessing with nevada leaders in
attendance such as the governor
and some clark county commissioners the
party inside
colorful and exciting resorts world
prides itself
in its luxury offerings and plethora of
food and drink options
which we're seeing on full display
tonight the property has a 117
000 square foot casino with cashless
wagering options something executives
say
puts resorts world miles ahead of the
competition
and the people we've talked to out here
tonight can't get enough of the modern
yet classic las vegas feel now back out
here live you can again see
a group of las vegas and visitors
entering resorts world
for the very first time again this wine
mentioned
the first property here on the las vegas
strip to open in more
than a decade so everyone definitely
wants to get a glimpse
we also spoke to people outside resorts
world waiting to get in some of these
folks earlier
that's where sasha loftus joins us live
now continuing our team coverage
and sasha what did they tell you
orca they said they were just counting
the moments until they could get inside
that brand new resort
resorts world las vegas on the las vegas
strip now
many we spoke to were actually las vegas
locals they said they were happy to come
down
to be part of this slice of history
from what i see everything looks great
after so much anticipation
resorts world las vegas is finally here
watching it be built and open finally
now that it's open we caught up with the
crowds
as they arrived for thursday night's
grand opening event
and the excitement was palpable it's
just amazing and then
like the time it's happening is just
awesome many from right here in the
valley were happy to make their way down
for the first from the ground resort the
strip has seen
in over a decade i've been here for a
lot of them
a lot of them i watched them and implode
the stardust as a matter of fact they
said they didn't want to miss this
classic vegas moment
they know we'll all remember forever
this is a strip so it's really cool it's
kind of a part of history ever since the
riviera was gone
now lines started forming tonight around
8 30 9 o'clock p.m
actually the first 2 000 people in line
at 9 00
were allowed to come in and kind of have
an outdoor celebration
with the dj in front of the resort and
of course the rain we saw tonight
did not stop people from coming out
reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now